diese hier gab es schon einmal aber wir
bekommen sie nur sehr selten rein ok und
wie viel kostet die
1490 lassen sie mich nach sehen um
sicher zu gehen
ja
1490 und diese hier
1790 diese hier sollte
2650 kosten
diese ist auch verfügbar für 3500 um die
4000 es ist kalbsleder mit stickerei
ansonsten gibt es auch pythonleder
zwischen 3000 und 5000 wie wäre es mit
dieser tasche aus krokodilleder
das ist die ultimative edel tasche für
29 sie ist wunderschön die farbe ist
wunderbar
29 bis 29.000 euro 29.000 euro
[Musik]
weltweit bekannte luxus designer
bekommen den wirtschaftlichen druck
nicht zu spüren in der modehauptstadt
drängen sich die menschen selbst an
einem normalen wochentag ihm unsere
reise beginnt im tempel der mailänder
designer labels im mode viertel die
königin der via montenapoleone ist gut
fürs image dieser marke basiert auf der
handwerkskunst der florentinischen
meister die lederwaren sind ihr
prestigeträchtiger nachfolger loslässt
das gleiche gilt für ortega benneter
dessen lederwaren an die in italien
hergestellten vicenza marken erinnert
die aber in französischem besitz sind
und zusammen mit yves saint laurent und
andere marken der kirin gruppe in der
schweiz abgerechnet werden
[Musik]
wie viel kosten die das sage ich ihnen
gleich
1490 und diese hier
1490 gleicher preis
[Musik]
welche marken stellen sie heute machen
wir alle möglichen marken
[Musik]
hauptsächlich aber sehr viel jimmy choo
und bottega veneta und auch salon
honorarberatung fast 10.000 stück
gemacht
was haben sie in letzter zeit
hergestellt wo ich die 40 stück richtig
hoch
sind die aus der neuesten kollektion
werden die im winter verkauft ich habe
sie von einem monat bekommen sie haben
mir sogar die nähmaschine gegeben wie
haben sie von gucci bekommen haben
benutzen sie sie ja wir haben eine menge
stiefel damit gemacht
sie fragte man aus tiefenthal
viele wollen sie denn
jeden tag etwa 100 paare aber sie sind
ziemlich kompliziert
jeden tag 100 paare
der mann mit dem wir gesprochen haben
ist ein zulieferer und in dieser
werkstatt werden die luxus schuhe
hergestellt die designer entwerfen die
modellbauer machen die prototypen aber
die großen modehäuser wenden sich an
hochrangige firmen die den auftrag dann
an subunternehmer also handwerker für
die eigentliche produktion weiter geben
unsere erste station um herauszufinden
wer die luxus taschen und schuhen ist
riviera der brienzer in der nähe von
venedig das kompetenzzentrum der
schuhindustrie das aushängeschild
italiens
der schuster hat uns geraten
hierherzukommen er meinte dass sie hier
schäfte hersteller geschäfte ja
ja
wir haben 2000 paar von diesem modell
hergestellt
die sind schön
das obermaterial ist der sichtbare teil
des schuhs das mähen ist der wichtigste
schritt bei der herstellung von schuhen
institutionen der lask kam die chinesen
haben sich auf diese produktion
spezialisiert
der hier ist so ähnlich welches modell
ist das
wer der garmo
wie viel zahlen die ihnen dafür
lassen sie uns hier weggehen um über die
preise zu sprechen bittet er uns von den
werkbänken weg zu gehen denn der betrag
den er vom lieferanten bekommt
entspricht nicht dem den er dem arbeiter
zeit der die schulen das habe ich nicht
verstanden wir bekommen 23 dafür ich
habe dem arbeiter gesagt na ja dass ich
ihm vier gebe und mir 6 so machen wir
das normalerweise by ferragamo ist der
preis höher
wie viele können sie erst 25 paare pro
tag paarweise sie bezahlen pro show ja
genau in dem sie arbeiten tag und nacht
damit sie mehr verdienen können
ja wenn sie sagen wollen dass das nicht
gerechtfertigt ist fast alle chinesen
arbeiten so es ist also sinnlos uns zu
sagen dass das nicht legitim ist die
bezahlung nach paar schuhen und
akkordarbeit sind illegal
wenn die schuhfabrik dem chinesen 23 eur
bid erhält der arbeiter vier euro für
die herstellung eines paars stiefel und
das ist ein modell aus der aktuellen
kollektion von ferragamo
guten morgen die sind von der letzten
brunnen schaut
sie setzten dieses jahr sehr auf diese
stiefel
wie viel kosten die
1550 ist es die schwierigkeit der
herstellung die den preis bestimmt
sicherlich sind dass die arbeitskosten
unsere schuhe sind immer noch fast
komplett hand gefertigt die würden in
italien hergestellt in florenz unser
hauptsitz ist in florenz für stellen sie
dort her das rechtfertigt auch den preis
[Musik]
wer gibt ihnen die aufträge von zerrung
glaube ich
dass sie wissen dass ein kontrolleur von
salomo war in der werkstatt und das zu
überprüfen
ich zeige ihnen ein modell von yves
sarault
dieses modell mit den kreisen und dem
knöchel riemen diese sandale ich weiß
nicht ob sie dieses modell kennen das
gibt es schon seit zwei jahren
diese hier möchten sie sie an probieren
darf ich sie zuerst sehen sicher
wie viel kosten sie
675 ja
wir sprechen über die tribut sandale ein
ikonisches modell von italo rang in die
stars auf dem roten teppich von adriana
lima kylie minogue jennifer lopez julia
roberts und beyoncé getragen wurde wie
viel zahlen die ihnen dafür die hier
neun euro 9 euro wie viele paare 10.000
jahr 10.000 99 euro nur für den schaft
und weitere vier für die beschichtung
wie viel würde ein seriöser italienische
handwerker kosten wahrscheinlich sehr
viel wenn man bedenkt dass seit dem jahr
2000 150 lokale schuhhersteller
geschlossen und 300 neue chinesische
werkstätten eröffnet wurden wir trafen
anonym einen zulieferer der schon immer
designerschuhe genäht hat
der coach ist die für den ich ihnen
gezeigt habe wird für 1300 bis 1800 euro
verkauft für diese gute stiefel habe ich
mark gezahlt 180 euro in den schuh
hersteller der mit den auftrag erteilt
das sind zehn prozent
das ist etwas was die leute nicht wissen
wollen was die tatsächlichen kosten für
ein luxus das material und die
herstellung höchstens 10 bis 15 prozent
des endpreises ausmachen alles inklusive
absätze montage allgemeine kosten
schachtel alles und diesen zehn prozent
die die marke bezahlt entfallen auf die
hersteller 40 bis 60 prozent der kosten
es hängt auch von der art der
herstellung von der art des schuhs ab
für die herstellung eines baums brocken
und 22
die kosten für einen handwerker werden
pro minute berechnet den aber die
bearbeitungszeiten können je nach schule
zwischen 20 minuten und vier stunden
variieren es sind die arbeitskosten die
sinken die kosten derjenigen die die
schuhe herstellen
sie schneiden dir die luft ab bei den
arbeitskosten
denn die chinesen unterbieten sie noch
mal um die hälfte wie können die die
hälfte der produktionskosten verlangen
die stadt acht stunden die arbeitszeit
verdoppeln oder sie werden unter dem
tisch bezahlt sie boykottieren und wegen
der stundensätze wenn ich seriös bringt
gar nicht ich weniger als 18 bis 20 euro
pro stunde verlangen sie fordern uns
immer wieder auf unsere preise zu senken
wie für sub unternehmer sitzen in der
falle
für die easa mourant sandale würden die
legitimen herstellungskosten also bei
rund 30 euro liegen der chinese sagte
uns er bekomme neuen euro plus 4 euro
für die beschichtung also weniger als
die hälfte wir haben einen schaft
mitgenommen dass im herstellungskosten
auf 30 eur geschätzt wurden
innerhalb eines tages sank dieser preis
erheblich
nur für das oberteil
nennen sie ihren preis dies soll das
entscheiden
15 ja das ist okay 15 ist in ordnung ja
und wie viel kostet das
88 gut das schaffen sie ja ja ist das
nicht schlecht nicht schlecht nein
[Musik]
wenn ich es wie für die luxusmarke mache
acht euro das heißt nicht mehr als acht
euro aber für acht euro würden sie es
machen
auf internationaler ebene gibt es kein
gesetz das die modehäuser zwingt ihre
produktionskette zu kontrollieren
derzeit hat sich nur gut sie mit der
ethischen zertifizierung s8000 zu seiner
sozialen verantwortung bekannt das heißt
dass der kunde sicher sein kann dass bei
der herstellung der produkte die rechte
der arbeiter in der gesamten kette der
zulieferer und sub unternehmer
respektiert werden
einige der marken der caring gruppe sind
in den letzten jahren vorsichtiger
geworden was die produktion betrifft
prüfen die vorzeige fabrik gibt uns
einige der schule und kleinen mengen
zu uns kommen und zeigen können dass sie
mit guten handwerkern arbeiten
wir sind nur eine fassade
großen mengen an die chinesen
wer ist schuld wenn die preise zu
niedrig sind die markenhersteller an der
spitze der kette die sub unternehmer die
schuhfabriken die einen vertrag mit der
zentrale unterzeichnen ohne transparenz
in der produktionskette ist es schwer
die verantwortlichkeiten zu bestimmen
auf diese weise können die unternehmen
wenn es um ausbeutung geht mit den
schultern zucken und sagen ich habe
nichts davon gewusst
[Musik]
die marken sind daran beteiligt denn sie
sind diejenigen die die preise vorgeben
zu denen die fabriken arbeiten müssen
es ist nicht mehr die fabrik die ein
angebot macht sondern es ist die
zentrale die eine produktionsrate
vorschreibt die fabrik dann innerhalb
der produktionskette wieder ausgleichen
muss das ist ihr problem
[Musik]
wir reden hier über ein produkt das
einen so hohen aufschlag hat dass alle
arbeiter gut davon leben könnten
wir haben mehr transparenz in der
produktionskette gefordert aber es
gehören immer zwei dazu um sich zu
einigen wenn die gegenseite nicht
mitmacht sie haben es nie genehmigt
unsere vorschläge wurden nie angenommen
sie sagten die fabrik sei geschlossen
aber sie arbeitete weiter nur die
chinesen sind noch da und die machen
urlaub
die entlassung wurde mit der schließung
des unternehmens begründet
mir wurde auch gesagt am samstag
arbeitest du acht stunden umsonst ich
habe abgelehnt um mir zu drohen haben
sie direkt einen arbeiter entlassen
[Musik]
wir wollen arbeiten es ist unser recht
regal zu arbeiten das ist alles wir sind
im zentrum von florenz eine gruppe von
13 senegalesischen arbeitern
demonstriert vor dem regierungsgebäude
ihr vertrag wurde nicht verlängert
nachdem sie um die legalisierung ihrer
arbeitsverhältnisse gebeten hatten es
handelt sich um die firma polesetter ein
chinesisches unternehmen das sich auf
metall arbeiten spezialisiert hat aber
nicht auf irgendwelche metallarbeiten es
geht um die designer schnallen von
luxusmarken hat die firma bekommt die
arbeit aus erster hand direkt von
gegenüber
unsere firma ist ihr mit diesem roten
tor
im hinteren teil des unsere werkstatt
die offizielle lieferfirma
die offizielle firma ist gleich dahinter
genau hier vor uns ja genau
hier kommen also alle original schnallen
an und was passiert dann sie bringen sie
nach vorne sie bringen sie dorthin wir
bearbeiten sie und dann gehen sie dahin
zurück wo sie herkommen wie viel stück
bearbeiten sie pro tag
an einem tag habe ich 3350 stück
bearbeitet
das waren schneiden für taschen
abdrucks aufgabe ist das einströmen das
bedeutet stundenlang über eine wanne
gebeugt zu sitzen und die schnellen für
designer taschen und schuhe zu polieren
und das ist eine sehr harte arbeit
[Musik]
arbeiten mit vielen verschiedenen marken
ich habe montags bis freitags 11 stunden
dann am samstag verschenke ich sechs
stunden für die mich niemand bezahlt
jeden samstag
geschenk benutzen die dieses wort
geschenkt sie sagen geschenkt das ist es
was sie dir sagen
schenkel mehr etwas oder er schickt
nicht so ist das chinesische gesetz
aber es gab nicht nur ein system des
schenkens von überstunden ein teil des
gehaltsschecks etwa 200 euro im monat
wurde unter dem tisch zurückgegeben
nimm dir alles weg aber ein regulärer
vertrag bleibt bestehen du musst das
geld in bar zurück zahlen
damit niemand es merkt niemand wird es
hier erfahren wenn du zb zur bank geht
sieht es so aus als hätten hättet ihr
alles ordnungsgemäß bezahlt
dann musst du das geld holen und es
ihnen zurückgeben
sie fragen sich was ist ihre bank sie
fand ich sogar hin du bist zum
geldautomaten und holst das geld
das tust verengen sie dein vertrag sind
es nicht tust schicken sie dich weg
das nennt man erpressungs aber auf diese
weise ist der gehaltsscheck sauber
ja hallo ich würde gerne mit dem
besitzer von polesetter sprechen wenn es
möglich ist
er will kein interview geben kann ich
mit herrn bin siege sprechen so heißt
hier niemand ist er nicht der besitzer
von einer der drei firmen ich weiß es
nicht auf wiedersehen
wir sind auf dem gelände der selben
firma die geschlossen wurde und früher
einen anderen namen hatte
nur eine minderheit der senegalesischen
arbeiter war mutig genug sich an die
gewerkschaften zu wenden
von den etwa 100 chinesischen arbeitern
kam nie eine beschwerde
[Musik]
chinesen haben keine ahnung sie kennen
nur die schirme und ihre heimat alles
andere ist ihnen egal
einige frauen wir arbeiten alle 13
stunden am tag
wie leben die chinesin schlafen sie dort
auf dem parkplatz
schlafen sie im auto rad erleben sie
die produktion in florenz hat einen
zusätzlichen wert die toskana hat eine
lange tradition in der herstellung von
leder und metall waren
gucci machte das in einer werbekampagne
sogar zu seiner stärke
anstatt die arbeit nach china zu bringen
holen sie die chinesin hierher
wir haben den spieß umgedreht
[Musik]
es ist kein zufall dass die entlassenen
arbeiter nachdem sie auf die straße
gegangen waren und die regierungen und
vor allem die zeitungen auf sich
aufmerksam gemacht haben jeder
eingestellt wurden es sei auch immer das
sind die luxus arbeiter und dies sind
ihre häuser
aber das produktionsarbeiter auf die
straße gehen um ihre rechte einzufordern
ist eine ausnahme vor allem dort wo
arbeitsplätze mangelware sind
neapel ist unsere letzte station es ist
eines der wichtigsten italienischen
leder führte die neapolitanische
handwerkstradition ist weltweit berühmt
bei welchen marken haben sie die
schlechtesten bedingungen erlebt
bottega veneta
gucci gucci war zu viel wenn die bezogen
auf die bedingungen ja
inwiefern
sie lassen dich einen drei stunden
vertrag unterschreiben sie bezahlen sehr
wenig wann sie wollen und wie sie wollen
einen vertrag über drei stunden drei
stunden am tag und wie lange haben sie
gearbeitet acht stunden oder sogar noch
länger
wie sieht es mit dem lohn aus sehr
niedrig 30 euro pro tag der letzte
loancheck
500 600 470 sie haben nur gut gemacht
nur gut fünf jahre lang ich arbeite
schon seit 25 jahren in diesem bereich
in welchem alter haben sie angefangen 12
13 der arbeiter der mit uns spricht hat
25 jahre lang als färber in fabriken von
zulieferern gearbeitet und das leder von
taschen und geldbörsen für große
modehäuser gefärbt seine aussage die
viel mut beweis ist nur ein beispiel für
eine situation die von den
gewerkschaften als desolat bezeichnet
wird
aber wenn eine fabrik dutzende von drei
stunden verträgen hat kann da niemand
den verdacht schöpfen dass es sich um
ausbeutung handelt
ich kann einfach nicht glauben dass die
geschäftsführung keine ahnung von einer
solchen situation hat
[Musik]
wenn das phänomen der schwarzarbeit der
unterbezahlung der rechtlosigkeit zu
groß ist das ist die überwiegende
mehrheit der luxus arbeiter betrifft
wie können sie es da nicht wissen
es ist unmöglich es nicht zu wissen sie
können mir schnell sagen es geht mir
nicht sagen ich habe ihn arbeit gegeben
fabriken sind verantwortlich ich wasche
seine hände in unschuld
wir sind am nördlichen stadtrand von
neapel hinter scampia und sekundär jan o
findet man in den gemeinden kassandra
abzahlung und kazuya viele lederfabrik
die meisten von ihnen sind keine
direkten lieferanten sondern
subunternehmen bei denen die vielleicht
schlimmsten zustände herrschen diese
fabrik in der via paolo borsellino ist
das sichtbarste geländes der rest der
fabriken ist schwer zu erkennen
die meisten fabriken in dieser gegend
sind wie diese gelbe her
so wehrt geschoss dieser häuser wohnen
leute
und geht einfach in den hof und sieht
statt einer garage eine kleine
lederwaren schuhe oder sogar eine
bekleidungs verbringt
es sind fabriken die nur illegal
arbeiten sie sind nicht registriert es
gibt sie eigentlich gar nicht aber auch
hier geht es um tausende von arbeitern
in dieser gegend ist schwer fabriken zu
finden in denen die arbeiter wenigstens
dem mindestlohn
kann sie einfach nicht finden es ist die
große ausnahme wenn mal ein findet
als die gucci inspektoren erwartet
wurden sagten sie sie kommen morgen
hierher räumt die fabrik auf die gute
inspektoren wollten com
aber wir wurden zwei tage vorher
informiert dass gucci inspektoren kommen
würden
wir mussten unsere mäntel ohrenschützer
und schutzbrillen tragen
die fabrik war so sauber davon konnten
wir den rest der zeit nur träumen
sobald sie weg waren war alles wieder so
wie vorher
haben sie die verträge kontrolliert ich
glaube schon haben sie sich jemals
irgendetwas gefragt sie haben die
arbeiter nicht direkt gefragt wie viel
verdienst du am tag wie viele stunden
arbeitest du
wo sind unsere rechte
wir arbeiten für euch aber was gebt ihr
uns
die situation ist so außer kontrolle
dass uns eine geschichte besonders
betroffen gemacht hat wo sie gefälschte
waren herstellen ein geschäft das
bekanntermaßen in den händen des
organisierten verbrechens liegt haben
sie manchmal auch die echte ware
erhalten
[Musik]
es gab eine beschlagnahmte werkstatt in
der bearbeiteten ich kannte den namen
meines arbeitgebers nicht
er rief uns immer mit einem wegwerf
handy an
entschuldigungen wie es ihr name
was geht sie das an er bezahlte uns
immer in seinem auto er drehte sich um
und nahm lachend das geld aus einem
umschlag oder einer schachtel auf dem
rücksitz das ist unsere situation und
wir haben früher gefälschte sachen
gemacht
aber sie haben gemerkt dass sie auch die
echten sachen herstellen manchmal haben
wir das wie konnten sie das erkennen
das fehlte bei der fälschung
diese kleine lasche innen die
herstellung war identisch identisches
wurde nichts geändert gleiches material
gleiche nähte gleiche farbe gleiche
herstellung
völlig identisch hat man ihn nicht
gesagt macht sie besser hinein es waren
einfach die selben die gleichen wie
lange haben sie gearbeitet
4 5 monate und sie schulden uns noch 100
das falschgeld war besser
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
das ist das absurde an der ganzen sache
wir reden hier über produkte von
unglaublichen wert aber die menschen die
sie herstellen werden unter dritte welt
bedingungen eingestellt wenn ich ein
unternehmen wegen der transparenz seiner
lieferkette und der löhne anklage weil
ich vermute dass sie zu niedrig sind da
war nicht ganz sicher bin anklage ich es
an weil es alles tut um geld zu sparen
und sie gefährden die fabriken die sie
eingestellt haben denn wenn die
fabrikbesitzer kaum über die runden
kommen können sie nichts tun sie
gefährden damit auch die arbeit sie
stellen das geld über alles andere sogar
über die würde der menschen dass kein
problem ist